えーと あの 心のところはもう終わりましたと思います
最後にローコールという心の説明ですが
出世堅心です 出世堅心というのは
まあ仏教におけるこの悟りの心で瞑想するとそういう悟りを開ける
出世堅心の違うところっていうのは
煩悩はもう完全に消えてしまうということなんですね
サマーディ瞑想をすると
煩悩は活動しなくなる
機能はしなくなっちゃうんですね
でもやっぱり可能性として心の中にあって
またいつか現れてくる
ですから この何か気持ちのいい体験することではもうあまり悟り開かないんだ
そうじゃなくて 体験として気持ちよくても悪くても
この真理をありのまま見ると心が変わるんだっていうのが仏教の立場なんですね
で それ普通の心理的な状態で
誰でもちゃんと物事を理解すると
また変わらない智慧が生まれてくるんです
で 何かジェットコースターに乗って
もう何か面白い体験したんだからといって心変わるわけじゃない
ですから このサマーディ瞑想終わったところで
智慧の瞑想をしなくちゃいけないと
そうすると真理はありのまま見えてくる
見えてきたら 自分今まで真理を知らなかったことと
真理を知らなかったんだから
いろんな欲やら怒りやら
ありとあらゆるこの千五百ぐらいの煩悩が生まれていたということがわかるんです
最初に理解するのは このものは永遠でないということ
無常であること それ理解すると同時に
主観的に自分にも永遠的な実体というものはないんだとわかるんですね
実体というものはないとわかったところで
いろんなこの精神世界に対する我々の妄想概念は全部消えるんです
で ということは いろんな宗教に対する自分の考え方は消えてしまうんです
それは一つの智慧ともいいし
一つのヴィシャンとも言うし
まあ哲学的な立場なんですね
正真正銘の真理を知っている哲学者みたいなところになっちゃうんです
哲学者というと何か物事を考える人なんですけど
この場合は物事を知る人になるんです
考えるということよりは
で なぜそう言うんですかというと
大体人間っていうのは
この私がいるということはまず考えているし
証拠はないし 証拠はないんだけど
私がいるんだと 私がいるんだから
いる私が誰ですか？とそれから考えちゃうんですね
そこに問題は私がいるんですか
ないかと まずそれはなんとか明確にしておかなくちゃいけないんですけど
それは前提として アプライアリーとして置いておいて
私がいる それは当たり前だ
そのいる私が何ですかとそれから考えちゃう
その考えると 一つの流れで哲学が生まれてくるし
一つの流れで宗教が生まれてくるんですね
ですから 世の中にある宗教という流れと哲学という両方の流れが
この私がいるというこの前提から生まれてくるんです
で 仏教はどんな宗教が正しいか
どんな哲学が正しいかということには
もう全然立ち触ろうとしない
それは仏教においては
それよりももっと根本的な問題があるんだと
その全ての流れが私がいるという前提から生まれたのではないかと
私がいるということは証明しているんですかと
何があって私がいると言うんですかと自己観察をするんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想というのは
そういう自己観察 で 自己観察すると発見するのは
いろんな情報というものが
それは物質的な流れで眼耳鼻舌身に触れると
触れる時はジュウという感覚というものが生まれると
感覚について気持ちいいものを聞きました
気持ち悪いものを聞きました
気持ちいいものを見た
気持ち悪いものを見たとか
我々は思ったりする その感覚について
私はというか 言葉がいきなり現れちゃうんですね
私が聞きました 私が見ました
私は感じた 私は考えましたと
私は嗅いだ 私は味わったと
ですから 私はというその概念が化け物みたいにいきなり入るもう一つの概念なんですね
そこで その概念なしに我々には考えられないんです
私はという概念なしに
ですから 我々のすべての知識が私はということはまずあるんだと
そこから生まれているんです
で その私はという概念がジュウから
ウェーダナーから生まれヴェーダナから生まれるんだと
ヴェーダナっていうのはこの感受性ですね
感受性 感じること で 何を感じるかというと
目で感じる 耳で感じる
鼻で感じる 舌で感じる
体で感じる それから心で感じるという６つのところで我々は感じるんです
ですから 感じることは６つありますよと言っても構いませんし
と言っても 感じるということでまとめれば一つだけなんですね
その感じることについて
私たちが私という化け物がそこで生まれるんです
ですから 人が私を触ったら
体を触ったら 私が私を触っ
触られたと言うんですね
人が何か言ったら 耳で聞いて私に言いましたと言うんです
ですから ただの言葉の言語学的な問題で
それで主観的に感覚としてあると思ってしまうという
そこでこのヴェーダナというものが本当はいろいろ違うんです
同じヴェーダナという魂
実体 個体ではありません
感じるものは個体であるならば
この感じる受体がありまして
それを我々が転生するんだとかって言っても構いません
神様が創造したのは その喜怒哀楽感じるその主体だと言っても構いません
もしそういう主体が個体があるならば
でも瞑想してみるとよくわかること
耳で感じるものと目で感じるものはそれぞれ違う
そこで耳で音を聞いていても
音によってこの感受というのはずっと変わっていくんです
同じ個体ではないんです
聞いてる音と同じく感じるヴェーダナもずっと流れていっちゃうんです
で 例えば目で何か見ていると
見ているものは物質 照明
変化して流れていく その流れに沿って見る感受性も変化して流れていくんです
だから 一つの流れに対して
新しい主観的な心理的な流れが生まれる
そこで個体がないということなんですね
哲学的に説明すると 悟りの境地
世界 で私がだからないと
それは我々が勝手に作った化け物だけですよ
で そこでそれは頭でわかるんだけど
悟らないんですね 悟らないのはこの無常という流れが体験しないんだから
見ているものはこういうところに壁があって
私が見ているんだと 壁に対してあると思っているんです
でも 壁というものはあるわけじゃなくて
生滅変化している一つの物質の流れなんです
音があって聞いているんだと思っちゃうんです
だから我々は客体に世界に対しても
色声香味触法に対しても
それはあるんだと その
いるんだと思ってるんです
そこはあるんだと思ってるんだから
感受性もあるんだと誤解しちゃうんです
じゃああるかないか見てみようと
じっと集中して一つだけ体験してみる
例えば音だけ体験してみる
目に入る光だけ体験してみる
体に触れる感触だけ体験してみる
その時はそれは流れていくんだと
同じものではないんだと
とわかるんです で わかったところで
次に じゃあ同じく自分も流れていくものだと
これは私ですよという体験がないんだと
とわかるんです 例えば歌を聴きましたと
その歌っていうのは ものすごく 1 秒間にもう 40万回とかね
もっとかなもうメガヘルツだからね
60メガヘルツとか 40メガヘルツとか
それぐらい変化して耳に触れるエネルギーなんですね
1 秒間にまあ 40万回変化するならば
そこでもう三時三分歌を聴いたならば
そこで歌ってどこにあるんですか？どこら辺が歌ですかと
ないんですね 全部まとめて三三分間の生滅随変化した流れに歌というだけで
で 歌っていうものは存在しなくなっちゃう
ですから 音を音を集中して聴いてみると
何か体で感じてみると
何かに集中してみると
この生滅変化の流れが見えてくるんです
体験してくるんです そうすると
自分の生滅流れも体験できるようになる
で その人は智慧が鋭い人であるならば
瞬時に あ なるほど 我はないんだと
実体はないんだと 主体はないんだと
という不審見というものが消えてしまう
でないと体験した人にとっては
またあるとは思えないんだから
たとえ いえ あなたどう言ったっても神様は作った作りましたよと言っても
それは認めないんですね
認めることできないんですね
なぜならば 人が知るということは
眼耳鼻舌身として知るしかないんですから
だから たとえ神様から聞いたとしたっても
その人が眼耳鼻舌身としてそれを聞いたんですね
そうすると 眼耳鼻舌身に入る情報も決まっている
色声香味触法ですから
それは生滅変化している流れであることしかなんです
ですから 別に驚きも何もないんです
そういう風に変わらない智慧が生まれてくるんです
この心のシステム 心のシステムを理解すれば
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは
そういう風にこの心のシステムを理解してもらうための方法なんですね
ですから この方法でなければこれ体験できないんです
たとえ呪文唱えたっても
何か頭の中で言葉を繰り返すだけで
で 悟れないんですね 例えばクンダリニ開発しようとか
チャクラ開発しようと頑張っても
チャクラという概念があって
それは開発しようとか
そうすると感覚でフィーリングで自分で
ああ 今おへそまで上がってきたんだと
今胸のなんとかチャクラまで行ったんだと
今喉の方のチャクラが開発しましたと
今額の音叉が開発しましたよというだけで
その何か感じているんですね
だから感じてること確かですけど
それを仏教で言えば自分だけであって
もう何もないんですね
眼耳鼻舌身意の意の方の感じか
体の方の感じか どっちか
あるいは両方か それは無常ですからね
その体験はすぐ消えてしまう
で そういうことでヴィパッサナーという瞑想が出てきて
それ何かまあ体験はありますけど
それは無常を体験する
自我を体験するんじゃなくて
無常を体験したら まあ自我がないということは
そこで初めてわかるんです
自我がないっていうのは否定的な言葉なんですけど
もう全く何もないという虚無的な意味ではなくて
流れてるんだと 物事は
ですから あるともないともという
どっちでもないんです
物事は因果法則によって流れていくんだと
瞬間の存在ですよと それ消えたら新しい存在が現れるんだと
ですから 仏教の真理っていうのは
自我がない あるという
どっちかに入るわけじゃないんで
本当のところは だから釈尊も特設魂はありません
全くないとか もう言いふらしたわけでもないし
あなた方は魂だと見ているものは魂にはならないんだと
認識はこの六つのチャンネルしか入りませんと
というと 正しく中道を守って我を否定しているんです
我を否定していると同時に
全く何もないという虚無主義も否定しているんです
何もないんだ 単なるもの
ただの空だという虚無主義も否定している
魂はあるという実体も否定している
因果法則で物事は因縁によって生まれるんだという仏教における中道ですね
それを教えているんです
だから仏教の立場からね
我がないんですよと言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
我はないというと いきなり否定的な言葉になって
何か否定することになりまして
ある即 あの 遍論に陥っちゃうんですね
本当は遍論ではないんです
それは中論なんです ですから
あるともないともではなくて
因果法則によって流れているんだっていうのは仏教の教え
それを理解することはサティの世界で
初めてみんなショックを受けるのは
ずっと自分がいると思っていたんだから
それをないと体験したら
これすごいショックなんです
ショックというよりはものすごく楽になるんですね
今まで無駄な苦しみを味わっていたんだと
余計な束縛によって余計な苦しみを味わっていたんだと
そういう瞬間にすごく楽を感じる
それは預流果というんですね
で それからさらに残っている煩悩はなくさなくちゃいけない
で 無我がわかっただけで全ての煩悩が消えるわけない
なぜならば 無我がわかっても
その人が美味しいご飯を食べると美味しいし
綺麗な音楽を聴くとすごく綺麗に感じるし
で 預流果に悟っても まあそういう風にもう体楽しみたいという
楽しみたいと言ったっても
もう体にはいい情報が入ると結構気持ちいいということ
気持ちは無常なんですけど
気持ちいいことには変わりがないんだと
という風になるんです
ですから 全ての煩悩が消えるわけじゃないんです
それで その人が 悟った人も
やっぱり食べる時はまずいものじゃなくて
当然ながら美味しいものは選ぶ
で 聞きにくい音を聞くんじゃなくて
聞いて楽しいことは聞いたりする
それでそういうものを探したりもする
で それでまた苦しみが生まれるんですよ
眼耳鼻舌身意 楽しめようと思っちゃうと
いくら無常だとわかっていても
そういうものを探し求めることは一つの苦しみなんです
でももう別にいいんじゃないか
その人は思うかもしれません
別にいいんじゃないかと思ったら
その分苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
それから その人はいい情報が入ると楽しいと思う
思ってるんだから 当然悪い情報が入っちゃうと気持ち悪いんですね
そうするとその預流果に悟った人はもう悩みがあるんです
どういう悩みかというと
貪りと怒りの悩みが残っちゃうんです
気持ち悪いものはやっぱり解除したいし
気持ちのいい経験は体験したいし
そうすると気持ち悪いものに対しては怒りの煩悩が生まれたり
気持ちのいいものについては欲の煩悩が生まれたりはするんです
ですから そこでさらに落ち着いた方がいいんです
そんな追っかけなくてもいいんじゃないかと
その落ち着きようも一つの悟りなんです
それは 2番目  3番目  4番目まで悟り分けてるのはそういうわけなんです
だから人がなぜいい体験も対しても
そんなにとらわれなくちゃいけないかと納得いかなくちゃいけないんですね
それそんな簡単に納得いかないんです
ですから さらに瞑想する
さらに瞑想すると 結局いい気持ちのいいものを追っていったっても
それすごい迷惑であって
もう大変だと よく感じるのは怒りかもしれません
怒りでは大変苦しみますから
いろんな怒りを感じたりしてね
自分に好ましくないもの
例えば子供の問題とか
家族の問題とか 商売の問題とか
そういうものに立ち触れなくちゃいけないし
そうするとうまくいかない場合は腹が立ったりはする
気持ち悪くなったりもする
それでそれを苦しいと感じる
じゃあそこら辺 怒りは収めないんですか？と思う
思わなくちゃいけない
でも怒りは一人で収めないんです
やっぱり欲もその分抑えないと
セットですから そうすると欲が欲しいと思っている限りは怒りは消えませんし
で その人はさらにさらに無常を体験すると
瞑想して瞑想して もっときめ細かく集中して心料を見ていくと
またいくらか心落ち着くというか
追っかけなくてもいいんじゃないかと
欲をかけると その分苦しみが生まれることと
その分怒りで悩まなくちゃいけないということはまた別で
いくらか欲を捨てる それは 2番目の悟りといって一来果と読むんですね
それでもまた残っているんですね
で 一来果になったら怒りと欲がすごく薄くなっちゃうんです
大胆な怒り 大胆な欲がなくなるんです
すごく普通の欲と怒りが残ると
さらに瞑想すると やっぱりいきなり納得いかないってことなんですね
さらに瞑想すると もう綺麗に怒りと欲が消えてしまう
それは不還果というんです
なぜ不還果というんですか？って
また存在には戻らないんですね
もう欲も怒りもないんだから
存在の中でも生きることはできないんですね
我々の欲界の世界では
原泥出身の世界では生きていられないんです
もう希望はない ゴミだと見たんだから
もう捨てたんだから で
それでどうやって阿羅漢になるかというと
さらに瞑想しなくちゃいけない
で 欲も怒りも捨てたんだけど
自分がいるという実感はまだあるんです
上が生まれるんだから
無常たる自分がいるんだと
すごいややこしいんですよ
自我意識っていうのは
で そこはその人は自分のこのアヴィッチャ
無明がまだ残っているとわかるんです
無常だとわかったんだけど
完璧に無常はわかってないんだと
だからどこかで まあ無常であっても
なんとなく瞬間瞬間でも自分がいる感じがあるんじゃないかなと
というよく気持ちがありますから
欲はもうないんですけど
そこで瞑想すると もう徹底的に無常を体験して
完璧に無明が消えちゃう
その瞬間で自我という意識は綺麗に消えてしまう
全く自我というのはない
全く自分という主観的な態度はそれで捨てる
綺麗に 主観的な態度を捨てることによって
また 5つの煩悩を消えちゃうんですね
それはこのルーパラーカ
ルーパラガって言って
色界に対する欲と無色界に対する欲
色界っていうのは ある次元に生きていたらいいんじゃないかって思う
それは主観的な感覚がある限りは
どこかで生まれ変わっちゃうんです
だからこの不還果になった人が決して人間には戻らない
神々には戻らない 梵天にいるんですね
梵天は色界か無色界なんですね
そこに至っても別にいいんじゃないかということですか
だから自分という主観があるんだ
自分という主観消え消えちゃうったら
もう色界に対する欲も無色界に対する欲も
それから混乱も情動も消えると
だから妄想することは消える
妄想することは綺麗に消えるのは阿羅漢になってからなんです
妄想というのは主観で生まれるんです
私がいるということから生まれるんですね
ですから 阿羅漢になるまでは結構悩まされるんですね
妄想 妄想が生まれると
情動という心の不安定が生まれるんです
心落ち着きがないと それも阿羅漢になるまであるんです
そんなもうそういうものは自動的に消えますけど
修行する人は綺麗に無明じゃなくて無常を感じて
無我感じて無明は綺麗に取る
無明を取るということは
主観という立場が全部綺麗に洗ってしまう
主観的にということは成り立たないんだと
私がいるというわずかな感覚も消えると
だからこの体に対しても
普通の世の中の一つの物質の流れとして見るだけで
自分という風に見ない
自分の体とは見ない ですから
釈尊でも他の阿羅漢たちでも
喋る場合はこの体 この心というふうに自分のことを言うんですね
私の体とは言わないんですね
あるある日 あるマコーサラ様がお釈迦様にも大変丁寧に礼をして
で お釈迦様がこう聞くんですね
あなたはなぜこの体にそんなに礼をするんですかと
すごい綺麗に森林の立場で物事を見るんですね
王様というこの物体が
この体というこちらにあるこの物体に礼をしているだけで
なぜこの体にそんなに丁寧に礼をしているんですか？ただ
その人は悟ってないんだから
私はお釈迦様はこういうこういうことで
こういうことで 大変気に入っているんですけど
またそれ説明するんです
そういうことで悟ったから
悟ってからは この体 この心というふうな状態で
このこちらにある体に心についても考える
そこまで我々は私がというところで考えちゃうんです
私の考えではとすぐ言っちゃうんですね
私はそう思いませんよとか
そこに完全に煩悩があるんですね
で この心はと思ったら
そこ煩悩 そこないんです
この心にはそういう考え方は生まれませんと
というと 私はということはないんです
だからといって悟った人々は私という言葉は使いません
使いませんということじゃない
使います それは一つの言葉であって
言語学的な立場では使っています
ですから 阿羅漢 のグループが森の中にずっと生活していたんです
で 社会に戻らないで そこでその森に住んでいた神々ですか
で この人々は阿羅漢です
達ですから 大変丁寧に守ってあげなくちゃ
面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないと思って
大変丁寧に面倒見てあげたんです
そこである日 このお坊さんたちがお互いに喋っているのを聞いたんですね
そこで私は何々と私の何々と
そういう風にしゃべるのを聞いて
あれ 悟ったと思ってたんだけど
悟ってないんだと まだまだ私がという概念があるんだと
やっぱりその神も仏教の論理的な立場を知ってるんですね
悟ったら私はということは消えるんだと
で 自分聞いた話では 私は使いますから
もう悟ってないんだと思ったんです
と思って お釈迦様にそういう話を言ったみたいですね
私はあまりにも性格が良くて
あのお坊さんたちがね
今もいる限りはもう悟っていると思ったんだけど
ずっと後で話を聞くと
こういう風に私という言葉を使うんだ
だからやっぱり悟ってないんだと
言ったら お釈迦様はもうそう言ってはいけないんだと
それはごく普通の世間的な
コンベンションですか
世の中の常識によって喋っているだけで
その人々はみんな悟っているんだと
ただ私はという言葉使ってるんだけど
私はという考え方になるんだけど
主観的な立場がないと言ったんです
とにかく悟る 阿羅漢になるということは
そういう私という主観的な概念も綺麗に消えるということ
それ消えていったら悟りであって
同時にもう煩悩は何もない
とらわれるもの何もなくなっちゃう
それで知ってるんです
自分が何にもとらわれないんだと
自分というものもないんだから
とらわれるという言葉さえも成り立たないんですね
自分という概念もなくなるんですけど
そういうふうなことで
その境地を説明するために出世間心という六処智ってなことを説明するんです
で 六処智とはだいたい 8つですね
8種類ありまして それは 8でもありまして
40にも化せるんですね
8っていうのは預流道
預流果 一来道 一来果 不還道
不還果 阿羅漢道 阿羅漢果というのですね
ソータパティマグガチッタ
パラチッタ サクダガーミマグガチッタ
パラチッタ アナガーミマグガチッタ
パラチッタ アラハントマグガチッタ
パラチッタ そこでマグガとパラと体験する境地とまとめてマグガ・パラニハンという言葉もなんかセットでミャンマーではよく使うんです
で だいたいテーラワーダの世界ではよく使いますけどね
みんな信者さんたちがこのマグガ・パラニハンという言葉を聞くと
すごくもう感動して もうサードゥ
サードゥって言います
何もわかっているかどうか分かりませんけど
何かありがたいではないかと思って
でもそれは大変深い意味なんですね
そんな簡単に理解できるものではないんですね
まあ一応こういうテキストを読むときでも
ミャンマーのテキスト読む時はよく出てくるんですね
ドーカ・ニハンという言葉が
まあ平気で書くだけだって
誰も読む人はわからないんです
ドーカ・ニハンっていうのは
今説明した世界のことを言ってるんです
一応どうやって出世間心が 40種類になりますかとというと
それはサマーディ瞑想の差なんですね
この前に説明しました
例えば第 1 禅定を体験して
それからヴィパッサナーすると
その人は悟りまで行く
さらにすると 彼には第 1 禅定に基づいた預流道
預流果 一来道 一来果 不還道
不還果 阿羅漢道 阿羅漢果が生まれるんです
ですから  第1禅定に基づいたその8と
そこで8になっちゃう
それで第2番目の禅定と作って
それから瞑想すると 第2禅定に基づいた預流道
預流果 一来道 一来果になっちゃうんです
そこでまた8が出てくる
第3番目の禅定にまで瞑想する
普通の瞑想して それからヴィパッサナーすると
それ人 その人の心には第3禅定に基づいた預流道
預流果 一来道 一来果が生まれてくるんです
で そのように第4禅定
第5番目の禅定まで  [咳]なるんですね
ですから ヴィパッサナーする前にサマーディ瞑想しているかないかということで
で そうするとサマーディ瞑想してからサマーディ体験があってから瞑想する
この 40種類のヴィパッサナー瞑想が出世間心が生まれる
どうやって 40種類というと
あの だからこの善心 位熟心
遊者心と 3つに分けているんですね
善心っていうのは その行為をするとき生まれる心は善心で
位熟心っていうのは行為の結果受ける時生まれるのは位熟心で
遊者心っていうのはもう悟った人の心が遊者心というんです
ですから  8種類の出世間心があります
それはあるいはあの禅定で分けちゃうと 5 かける 8ですね
あ 間違った 出世間心の場合は善心ないんです
道と果だけなんですね
道と果だけです 遊者心とか生まれない
ですから えっと 第5種類の禅定から 8種類の出世間心が生れる
ですから  8 かける 5 は 40になる
それだけ で それで問題が生まれるんです
例えばサマーディ 何もしないでヴィパッサナーだけしたならば
ヴィパッサナーだけして悟りましたと
そうすると純粋な出世間心 8 だけ生まれるのではないかと
じゃあ純粋な出世間 出世
出世間心 8 とサマーディに基づいた出世間心 40 と 48種類があるんじゃないかとという問題が生まれるんです
40種類に入るためには
まずサマーディ瞑想をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから 出世間心48種類ありますよと言っても構いません
構いませんだけど アビダンマではそう言わない
アビダンマではこのヴィパッサナーだけしても
悟る時は自分の心は第1禅定のところまで成長するんだと
全くサマーディ瞑想しなくても第1禅定まで
進むんだ ですから 純粋なヴィパッサナー瞑想の純粋な出世間心
純粋なヴィパッサナー瞑想をして出世間心が生まれても
それは第1禅定を基盤にしているんだと
言って 8か40かどっちかにします
そういうことで 心は 121か 89種類になっているんです
で それで心の分析は終わります
今日喋るの大変難しいです
で 次にまた我々は戻らなくちゃいけないんです
で 心の分析も少々覚えておかなくちゃいけないし
心はアクサラチッタ 不善心は十二がありますと
それがアディエッタチッタ
無因心は十八あるんだと
次にカーマソーダナ チッタは二十四あるんだと
カーマソーダナチッタも言うし
えっと 日本語で何て言います？ 六蓋情心
あ 六蓋情心っていうのはカーマソーダナですね
六蓋情心って言って これは善心なんですね
これは不善心で カーマソーダナチッタっていうのは善心
それは二十四種類ありまして
それから瞑想する人々にはルーパシャティチッタという
色界の心が十五もあるし
無色界の心はアルパチッタと言いますね
チッタは十にあるんですね
色界の心は十五と 無色界の心は十
で そこでこの前の三つ
アクサラチッタ アディエッタチッタ
カーマソーダナチッタっていうのは欲界
五十四ですね ルーパチッタは色界
アルパチッタは無色界
で ここら辺はマハッカッタチッタと呼んで
いわゆる瞑想して成長しなくちゃいけないんだから
この五十四の心は誰にでも生まれる可能性あるんです
この中でも誰にでも生まれない心も八ぐらい
八じゃなくて九ぐらい入ってますけど
阿羅漢だけに生まれる心は
でも心としては独仏に生まれる心ですから
努力しなくても誰にでも生まれるという
で こちらの心にはマハッカッタチッタと言うんですね
大心 マハッカッタ これ
つなげるんですけど きちんとそのことは
マハッカッタチッタ マハッカッタというのは内心
もう成長する心がこれぐらいあるんだと
それから世の中と存在と何にも関係ないローコッタチッタ
ローコッタチッタ八か四十かどっちかなんですね
ローコッタチッタ八で数えてもいいし
四十で数えてもいいです
ですから 前の五十四はカーマチッタ
欲界心 次に来る二十七は内心
最後に来る八か四十には出世間心と分けてます
また この中のいろいろ分け方ありまして
その分け方は全部それからやらなくちゃいけないんです
やらないと このアビダンマっていうのはそそけない
なかなか理解しにくくなっちゃうんです
で その分析するのは大体それなんです
心性の勉強終わってから
いろいろ分析にいっちゃいますけどね
やっぱり暗記していないと
なかなか難しいんですけど
まあそれ いろいろチャートなんかも
高井さんそそっているから
自分で勉強して 私には言う権利がないんだけど
皆様話し合って コピーしてもらっても構いません
テキストにもそれなりのチャートが書いてあるんです
そのチャートを見たらわかると思います
[咳]